see this is where he gets on my [ __ ]
nerves
qc is the result of feminism
i already know now i'm an [ __ ]
because i said that out loud on video
last time we watched entertain you only
gave him a six out of ten hey you're
lucky you're getting a six which i i
don't understand how you did that and
today we're gonna be watching him debate
with this guy xqc um just some canadian
twitch streamer they disagree on a lot
of stuff like i'm sure a lot of people
disagree with tate it's interesting just
gonna get our thoughts because people
like to hear you talk
god knows you do
you're right
i mean
aiden messaged me and said andrew
quickly wake up someone disagrees with
you
okay good introduction because that's it
that's how it is who disagrees with me
along what
um
i think at least me i i think i disagree
with most things but i think i don't
know about train though i don't think he
knows you that much all i saw was a
couple a couple clips of you and i i
didn't want like um wikipedia whole
search i wanted to take the the argument
and it takes for what they are and not
what like where they they come from or
whatever just shut up place value
that's what you get you have something
specific you disagree with me on
oh yeah most of your women thinks are
bad
[Laughter]
wait a minute does anyone in your
generation speak in a full sentence i
don't i this isn't almost impossible to
follow for anyone who can read a book
all right sorry yeah i think he's french
canadian i'm sure he's lovely i'm sure
he's lovely but
speak speak more concisely
like
it's too much work to understand what
he's trying to just what what just
happened you can't say literally most of
them this is a court of law my friend we
have a judging panel and everything you
have to come along
that you disagree with and give your
argument as to why it's not true you
can't just say i can't drive
woman can't drive was one of them yeah
that was kind of weird
so you don't think that men are overall
better drivers than women
no
so when you see the worst parking you've
ever seen
why'd you spit out your drink
i can't say what i really think yes you
can
it's not all women that are worse
drivers than men
it's
man
it's asian women i'm sorry
i'm sorry
it's not a racist thing certain
stereotypes exist for a reason
i'm sorry that i'm sure they're all
going to have something like he says
types about you and that's fine and you
know what they're probably at least in
part room
yeah i'm sure that's i'm sure that
you're speaking from personal experience
and your own personal bias like if
you've seen some someone cut you off and
it's a it's an asian woman you're like
it's always this [ __ ] asian woman
cutting me off you know that that's like
his point is like from personal
experience he's seen the majority like
the majority of [ __ ] drivers he's seen
it's a woman so if the majority they've
never seen me at parallel park though
you know oh yeah you're a great parallel
parker yeah but it's it's all about your
parents driving like a lunatic i can
parallel park like a like a champion
you're a good driver
bit crazy like like i said it's not it
doesn't have to be an opinion right that
is your anecdotal evidence which is like
kind of a bias right
when you want to bring out things like
women can't drive you're going to go
with stats and your stats are off you're
you're just wrong about them well
everyone is firstly firstly when you
talk about biases absolutely everybody
is biased to their own personal
experiences right if i've been in five
car crashes and all five of them were
driven by women by coincidence i'm going
to be biased
he did mention uh whatever this young
excuse me
i don't even know his real name his
point was you know it's anecdotal
evidence but anecdotal evidence is very
important in forming opinions personal
opinions and it does have some effect
some value but not as much value as
actual hard data but anyway
i i don't want data on this i already
know now i'm an [ __ ] because i said
that out loud on video it's fine i can
live it what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do like a natural good
educating been being you're probably
gonna go on internet and find some study
that maybe you maybe you're right about
it and then you're gonna figure out that
you're wrong
study oh yeah the internet study oh why
didn't i think of just following the
internet studying you're right because
we could have gone [ __ ] experience
instead
all my own personal experience and obey
the internet study and get my fifth
injection and just do everything the
internet says you're all
personal experiences females people are
driving as males that's my personal
experience you can't come along and tell
me that's not true so and i don't give a
[ __ ]
buddy so
we have a problem with science or some
[ __ ] or physics why why go to the
internet or talk some experts let's go
with ask kate's experience on it and
we'll have the answer to it right
i mean do you have any thoughts there
because i think he's more talking about
like personal bias but you also have to
take anecdotal evidence into accounts
because it matters
yeah like what you see why am i going
out and advocating asian women shouldn't
have driver's licenses no
no
i'm just saying most of them can't park
that's all that's all you know asians
are better at other things you know i'm
terrible at stop signs i just kind of
i'm like uh it's a suggestion but maybe
the asians are like god those white
[ __ ] don't stop you know
i don't know
i'm just saying we all have experiences
and they form opinions and it doesn't
make us racist yeah no i feel you anyway
i agree or sexists no yeah but people
will say that that's what it is because
that's what they do yeah let them talk
i'm half black half white right that's
my ethnicity
i made a joke
an hour ago with one of my cousins
because half my family's black half my
cousin's white
and he said he wanted to go uh
free diving that's where you dive down
in the water and you go deep with no
scuba equipment with the sharks or some
[ __ ] and i said whoa that's what white
people do that [ __ ] i'm too brown for
that i'm not going with the sharks i
just i just made a joke there oh no
cancel me who gives a [ __ ] when i make a
mistake when i make a statement bro
listen when i make a statement maybe you
do maybe you have all the [ __ ] time
in the world to sit on the internet my
friend but when i make a statement i
don't have time to say in my personal
experience i don't believe women can
drive however i understand that some
women can drive and i'm not saying all
women can't drive and i know women who
can drive but in my personal experience
the bad driving i've seen was most
likely committed by women that i don't
talk like a [ __ ] geek
i say women can't drive now i just said
what he said a couple minutes ago yeah i
know exactly my own way
yeah and he's also doing that on purpose
i mean he's a good marketer he knows
that by saying something like woman
can't drive it's going to end up getting
more views than going into this whole
[ __ ] tangent you know
yeah he and i differ in that way he
understands marketing and he does it
that he does it sort of on purpose i
just i'm just speaking naturally
oh is that speaks like you cool whatever
because geeks don't give a [ __ ] that's
what i say if it upsets people tough
that's my personal experience you're
gonna have to get the [ __ ] over that's
life
if you want to say i'm a bad
communicator once again that's your
prerogative but i would disagree i think
i'm a very good at community
communicating that's all the reason i'm
even [ __ ] here the only reason i'm
even on the internet because when i talk
people listen so i must be doing
something right i mean it's it's that
result misogynist that's really easy
it's one of the easiest things out there
preaching to the choir that's so easy to
begin following doing that
he's not
in that particular statement i don't
think tate is a misogynist yeah by
saying that women can't drive yeah he's
got some misogynistic things but like
everybody finds so much offense in
everything
just because estating an opinion doesn't
make you a racist a misogynist a
homophobe anything doesn't it's [ __ ]
and it's frustrating to watch people get
so offended it's the same [ __ ] as like
when what was the baseball team the
indians they got like friggin white
people got so offended over the name the
the indians and then the actual native
americans weren't even offended like it
made no sense i had an opinion one day
online about a blm issue or whatever and
some lady was like you're white you
don't you don't how could you speak for
black people and i looked at her profile
picture and i was like you're looking
pretty quite yourself andrew the uh one
of the one of the takes that you made on
my stream about um that you should take
100 of you know your girls only fans
i know actually you you felt some type
of way about that
um
yeah andrew you that's still i mean
they say that you're joking 100 and you
weren't joking so i i you know when only
fans is right
uh enough to understand follow along
yeah like you know your own link can buy
you so freaking crazy picks people men
pay money that kind of that kind of you
know well it depends right so if it's a
girl who were to come to me and say
andrew i would like you to help me make
money on only fans and they would come
to me for my marketing expertise and of
course it would be a fair deviation i
make 20 30 whatever that's different but
if it's my girlfriend my long term
partner we're going to be together
forever and she decides to go down that
particular career path i think i should
have a much larger stake because she is
my girl and she is now giving away some
of the most private intimate parts of
her body to the internet those parts of
her body belong to me effectively
because she's my woman that's the whole
point of being with somebody so to be
pretend to do that make a bunch of money
and give me nothing is i find that
disrespectful i would i would sooner
tell her look you're not doing only fans
and she would
so i called it
what do you think of that a guy taking
100 of his girls only fans money i mean
strange it's such a weird hypothetical
strangers get a better deal
than the woman that you supposedly love
that's just weird to me but he's saying
like the strangers it's like a business
interaction and his woman it's like his
woman
like he owns her yeah that's that's how
he that's how he thinks yeah he doesn't
but you know it's such a waste of her
because he's her best friend right mr st
and then you help her and if she's a
decent woman of course she's taking all
of her earnings and putting it all on
the family table in the same way
yeah as he is it's also such a slow but
he's contributing to his success also so
yeah
and it's not like he's not buying her
[ __ ] he's probably buying her a bunch of
stuff
like what he's top g takes care of his
girls see this is where he gets on my
[ __ ] nerves well it depends yeah
depending on how they make it absolutely
i think that in a relationship with a
woman if the man is with that woman the
main reason he knows he's with her is
the fact that she is sexually exclusive
to him if you're with a woman she's
[ __ ] everyone i wouldn't say like
that's the main reason but that's like a
part of why you're in a relationship
that's not why you're in a relationship
that's a just an expected factor of why
you're in a relationship even with her
no how do you know she's even yours
because she only sleeps with you right
well if all of her intimate parts are
now for everybody and they're
purchasable then i think you have a
stake in said parts because those parts
belong to you she gives them this lady's
really going ham on his back you got to
take a look i know i wish she was here
right now i got to get a personal next
video
asian ladies get better massages
they might not be as good at driving but
they give killer massages
i don't know if they give the best but
they do give killer massage how often do
you go to massage place and it's not
like asian people giving massages that's
pretty rough almost every time i don't
know what places you're going to but
yeah really oh yeah okay
do we need to talk personally if my
woman were to come to me and say she
wanted the only fans i just say no
because i know
okay then what exactly
yeah i mean respectfully let's have an
uh
let's try to upscale that discussion and
see
what what kind of stake would you need
for your girl to suck another guy's dick
i would never tolerate that on any level
so that's too far but well i mean
there's a price for the pictures and the
loss of intimacy you know people say
there's no such thing as a stupid
question
there's a perfect
example it's a huge this is just a
freaking stupid question
yeah that is why would you even ask that
he's just trying to be controversial now
and yeah like what what kind of
productive conversation yeah that's just
what no that was just stupid would you
let your girl [ __ ]
pictures on the internet are very
different than sucking it actually
so i would never let this is just crafts
i mean i i'm not all right all right i'm
sorry i didn't mean for it to get this
far let's just skip i'm still your
mother i did i'm cool and i'll talk
about it i wanted to watch the only fans
part i didn't realize that was all
common i'm sorry we're talking about
masculine duty and authority and
responsibilities we're not so
hypothetical let me change it you and
your woman are asleep in bed upstairs
you hear someone break into the house
downstairs who goes downstairs nobody
yeah
right away yeah is that nice goes
downstairs
yeah honey go [ __ ] get them all right
that's what you do
right yes
job is to survive not protect my job is
to survive and sometimes that means to
get to go down another guy's a gun it
doesn't matter what the [ __ ] i do
we are both going down by doing by doing
the smart thing the analytical thing the
strategic thing
we can both survive if i go down not
only am i jeopardizing myself i am
jupitering both of us
[ __ ] mary this is
okay that's all there is to it we are
even more in danger if i go down if i'm
not going over your head stop for a
second you have the high ground you are
up the stairs you have so much power
over whoever is on the lower level like
just from
basic
battle strategy start throwing [ __ ] down
the stairs simple fortnite strategy if
you have the high ground you're more
likely to win how hot you're hiding
though you're hiding so
like you gotta try to protect your girl
what
guys are crazy
bro bro you are losing your you live in
america right no you're losing your mind
okay my job is
attracts women with daddy issues who
just are looking for approval they'll
take any [ __ ] that comes along with
it that's all there is to it this guy
um whatever xqc or whatever he's he's
like
going for the woke girls who think that
a man that is just totally effeminate is
okay and that's what they want and they
think that's what they want until
someone comes in breaks into the house
and then they're like all of a sudden
they go into natural mode and they think
oh my god go down and check it out and
he's like no you go down and then that's
another troubled chicken man yes chicken
man's the man so far he said i need to
know more about him but right now solid
10 on chicken man it's the only thing he
said tonight and
go out there and protect the family
chicken man's the man if you don't
believe you have any kind of intrinsic
masculine duty to at least attempt to
protect your female
then that explains why we disagree on
every single point yes not i'm looking
forward friend that i even have a
even higher duty to not protect her to
not even protect myself i have a duty to
form and survive
surviving in this scenario means if
somebody breaks in the house he's okay
listen andrew
if somebody breaks the house he is more
likely than not likely to have a certain
tool to get in or a weapon if i do not
possess that weapon right i am not
he's screaming in the mic so loud it's
not even picking it up
going down there with bare hands
because we will both die
you can have a weapon i'm not saying you
don't have a weapon i'm saying oh
another another all and then you break
it down another [ __ ] argument like
that bro you need to stop doing that
he's so emotional he's laughing at him
yeah because he's laughing at him and
he's like this guy's emotional like a an
emotional broad that's what he's
thinking i'm not saying that i think
emotion is okay but this guy is so
emotional that tate's looking at him
like this guy's a lady how could your
instinct not be to go down and like even
think about sending a girl [ __ ] girls
aren't meant to deal with high stress
situations like that they [ __ ] freak
out it's not even that it's that we can
get like we
are
genetically speaking overall and i don't
want to hear from all the strongest
[ __ ] on earth like how this is wrong
but like
we are
we have smaller muscle mass
shorter reach
we can't fight the same as men we have
slower reaction time in our muscles to
recover there's all the normal actual
science that exists
that we can we can go down there and
fight and we can win but
the dudes got a
over a way better chance it's just
statistics got a better chance simple
not this guy what
what if what if i have a gun i go to the
back and i make her i got go open the
door and i blast them
now we both
so you went good fine i answered the
question okay i'm not
i'm just trying to
try actually they're just going in
circles and stupid hypotheticals over
and over yeah well
tate's keeping the hypotheticals very
simple yeah now he's literally just
saying if someone breaks in does a man
or a woman doesn't matter if they have a
gun or he can't comprehend it if he
reverses actually i'm pretty bad
shooting let's say i open the door then
she shot am i still the man
i'm trying to make you guys understand
well no no no no no no am i still good
now that opened the door and then she
shot or is that not good enough
that's fine but that's not the scenario
i described then i'm describing or the
fact that what is he describing it's
like he he set up a tactical strategy
[ __ ] ground three out opens the door
she's there with like a rocket launcher
what like what is he even talking about
this guy is ridiculous i open the door
and she starts blasting [ __ ]
somebody has to engage and it's the
man's job just like the men stay on the
titanic the men go to fight that's a
man's imperative and i don't care
doesn't matter that i can fight if i'm
not number 10 to one they have machetes
and i'm going to lose fine no one's
going to rape my chick without me trying
that's my masculine imperative and my
duty as a man the point i'm trying to
make is let me change the scenario
you're upstairs you have an ar-15 three
unarmed men break in between you and the
chick one of you has to take the gun and
go down there and deal with all three of
them remember that movie i told you
about
yeah nobody with bob odenkirk from
breaking bad he
it starts with this scenario happening
in his house you have to see this movie
it is so good
okay
can you see whatever needs to see it
maybe he'll get a little testosterone
out of it go shoot him
why she's kidding you know
why only can she be uh did you be scared
if she just trained better better than i
do if she's better tonight than i am
she's taking a couple i'm not i'm fine
oh what
am i talking about bro if she is a
shooter she's gonna go you're gonna send
your girl downstairs
i don't know if she's a bro
a woman even is she even able to combat
against three
against three men
realistically in this situation there
was an ar-15
and three unarmed men she's fine but she
is a gun owner and you know i don't know
if she's a guy i don't know i feel like
one of the guys just [ __ ] runs at her
and just gives her a whack and the gun's
flying you know that's just the way i
see it but what do i know so what we've
learned from me asking this question is
that you and not this is not insult i
think you'd agree with me saying this
you have no intrinsic desire no
intrinsic duty or intrinsic innate
responsibility to protect your female in
any regard xqc is is the
result of feminism
feminism gone wild like over the top
turning men into
women that's what they want to do and
look they've done it they're not turning
tate into a woman and that chicken guy
probably not him either i'm willing to
die for my girl is that insecure that's
not the scenario that's not the scenario
like
there's no
right
yeah
obviously clearly
you got a bigger right right right
you're you're you're the bigger head box
okay you're sleeping and you you you the
hell is this [ __ ]
okay
right so this is this guy who is losing
it in a conversation i i can't imagine
sleeping well at night next to him
feeling safe
if something was to go wrong
this guy would freak out in new york let
freak
like
alone pull out tactical strategies to
open the door for his girl for her to
shoot a rocket launcher through
you'd be too afraid to even have a gun
in the house this guy your gun is the
only way you're going to try this again
okay the magazine is under the bed and
your bed is real and it's both of the
[ __ ] it's pulled to the ground right
do you say hey girl get the loader under
the bed with your small arm i can go
through it and get the maggot or you say
bro lady back up woman woman back up
you're the woman i got this
what was that point even
that was so stupid again
feminism gone wrong because you you yes
you do say you did
stay here i'll be right back
i'm gonna go kill some [ __ ] i'll be
right back you guys are on a hike it's
you and your girl a [ __ ] bear comes
out of nowhere
i'm i'm i'm gonna i listen we're not
escaping this so i'm gonna say run and
let the bear [ __ ] do have its way
with me bro i'm gonna die
and she's gonna live that's what i'm
gonna do if i that's my girl bro i can't
i'm gonna do that i can't correct okay
okay
that's right
if the girl knows what to do because she
has knowledge about about the bear
approach where she could sing or talk in
a way to make her survive i shut the
[ __ ] up
you heard that now she's snowing he
wants her to [ __ ]
[Music]
when the bear appears you don't sit
there and argue with your chicks saying
well you went to veterinary school so
you're better with bears and maybe you
could take a beard
you have a duty as a man to protect your
female is your duties your masculine
imperative all of humanity consists
shows it's true all of history shows
it's true and for you to sit here and
say if someone breaks into my house i
have no duty at all to protect my woman
if she's scared and crying i might send
her ass down there because i can't shoe
shows that you have no intrinsic you
have no intrinsic desire to protect or
provide or look after that female which
is why you have no frame in your
relationship
who
a man who thinks he can send his chick
downstairs to [ __ ] engage our mom i
know i'm wasting my errors
i'm surprised he held on that long
yeah i know that was a that was a great
little ring he went on i mean not
he's not even making any sense anymore
like there's no logic coming into the
equation you're not a gladiator don't go
after the bear i can sing to the bears
what are you talking about dude he's
like yeah i am a gladiator actually and
now
yeah go get your nails done i'll pick
you up after i'm going to fight this
bear that's [ __ ] ridiculous given the
choice yeah tate do you give tate a new
rating after this or is it still at a
rock and a six tate gets a straight 10.
all right tate you're up now
not that he gives up [ __ ] what i think
but if he did yeah he's up to a 10 for
for
for this situation
yeah well you're also comparing them to
a [ __ ] mary so
well no
let me taste the man
i'm denying it all right
yeah thank you guys so much for watching
another great video um i'm gonna be
giving away a hundred dollars to someone
who likes and subscribes and then dms me
proof on my instagram sunnyfast love you
all am i eligible
[Music]
on my